the Zelda games are known for many  things and I'm willing to bet you have  at least one favorite song from the  soundtracks I'm Tony and this game spot  news update is bringing those classic  tunes back hero of time is a 21 song  collection of tracks from Ocarina of  Time played by a full sixty four piece  Orchestra you'll find tunes you remember  like Hyrule Field and Castle Town market  totally reimagined project director Eric  Buchholz says it takes a quote  east-meets-west approach so you'll hear  some additional Japanese instruments in  the mix hero of time is releasing on  bandcamp and itunes and you can grab  limited edition CD or vinyl versions as  well it's 14 bucks for the digital  soundtrack or 30 for the CD when they  launched on March 27 and it's 40 bucks  for the vital when that releases in the  coming months and if you want your Zelda  fix right now check out any one of our  videos on the many things that breadth  of the wild doesn't tell you  [Music]